Hi, I'm Aimee Mullins.
I'm the new brand ambassador for L'Oreal Paris.
Things that I'm celebrated for whether it's from sports or you know, fashion...
...having been, in spite of, even because of, what I've learned and have experienced...
... as a woman living with two prosthetic legs.
We don't need to fit in to someone else's idea of what beauty is.
Decide for yourself and invent the version of yourself that you want to see on that day.
And for me, it's like it's in a very literal way, could be changing my height.
Changing the kinds of legs I wear actually changes the way I feel.
The slogan of "Because you're worth it."...
...had a resonance that connected women to something bigger than themselves.
For me anyway, it provoked something totally unexpected,...
...which was giving myself the pat on the back.
Being my own cheerleader I'd say, "Yes, you are enough!"
When I filmed my first commercial, it was a great experience.
For a lot of it, it was just, I was actually taking my voice down to a whisper.
We wanted to create this mood of intimacy like I was revealing something.
For me "Because I'm worth it.", it's an incredibly personal thing.
There were different emotions that were provoked,...
...realizing like wow, that actually was hard to say that time.
That actually almost made me cry or well, that was interesting.
There was some kind of defiance that came out when you said it at that time.
What happened there, that it can mean something very personal is...
...I think what makes this tagline and the signature for L'Oreal Paris so iconic.